DC movies might be about superheroes
striving to make the world a better place,
but they're not all sunshine and daring
rescue -- a lot of characters, good and bad,
don't survive. We're here to take a look at
their last words before they meet their maker.
Superheroes are often created as an answer to
global unrest, rising to solve violent conflicts
that previously seemed insurmountable. General
Erich Ludendorff in 2017's Wonder Woman stands in
dramatic contrast to this: he's actually based on
one of the real-life villains of the 20th century.
After contributing to significant German military
victories in World War I, Ludendorff became a
major factor in the Nazis' rise to power. He was a
vocal proponent of the myth which blamed Germany's
defeat on home-front sabotage by multiple
groups, most prominently the Jewish population.
Obviously, his demise in Wonder Woman is
well warranted. He views war as a god that
bestows meaning on men, while requiring
sacrifice. This leads to what appears
to be a grudging respect for Diana, simply
for her power alone. At the end, he says:
"As magnificent as you are,
you are still no match for me."
He turns out to be dead wrong.
As dangerous as General Ludendorff is to the
world, especially through his collaboration
with Dr. Poison, the greatest threat in Wonder
Woman is otherworldly. Ares, the Greek god of war,
has been seeding destruction for a long time.
He implants ideas of war in the minds of humans,
but insists that their natural corruption
is what actually leads to violence.
Diana, in contrast, believes that the most natural
quality of humanity is love. As much as the world
might forget this, it's the most important
virtue, no matter what terrors pop up. As she
and Ares duke it out, he tries to take advantage
of her grief over losing Steve Trevor. Diana
asserts that she's devoted to her belief in love,
despite the pain of Steve's death. Ares responds:
"Then I will destroy you!"
These words are his last. Diana
redirects his lightning back at him,
just as she redirects grief into love.
Steve Trevor's goodbye in Wonder Woman is
heartbreaking, especially since he's the
person who helps assure her that
humans have goodness inside them.
When Diana and Steve infiltrate a gala
for German High Command, she hopes to
confront Ludendorff, who she believes is Ares.
She's bewildered, then, when the general dies
and the war rages on. Diana still has a lot to
learn about human evil at this point, but also
about human goodness. Steve gives her a lesson
in virtue when he makes the ultimate sacrifice.
When Diana attempts to stop him, he
refuses. He originally tells her:
"It has to be me. It has to be me. I
can save today. You can save the world.
He regrets that they don't have more time,
and Diana interjects to ask what he's
saying. All he has left to tell her is this:
"I love you."
One of the surest signs of goodness is the ability
to see good in others. In his last
words, Steve exhibits this quality:
he knows what he has to do, because he knows Diana
is the only one strong enough to save the world.
In Man of Steel, Faora, Zod's loyal
second-in-command, dies on the ship that crashes
into the Black Zero prison craft. This collision
opens a black hole that sucks Faora and the crew
into the Phantom Zone. Faora actually doesn't
speak in her final scene, and her final words
in the film are a rather pedestrian few. Zod
gives her command of the ship, and she says:
"Faora, take command."
"Yes sir."
Not long after, Faora tries to stop
the last ditch effort to counter
Zod's plan. The hero of the day
winds up being Colonel Hardy.
As Hardy flies Kal-El's ship to Metropolis,
Faora hijacks it. He realizes that the only
way to stop Zod is to sacrifice himself.
In the moments before their assumed demise,
Hardy repeats the words she said to him in
an earlier encounter. He echoes her and says:
"A good death is its own reward."
Going out the way they do
probably isn't what she meant.
Towards the end of Man of Steel, Zod threatens to
destroy a family of innocents to show Superman how
futile his desire to protect humanity truly is. As
Zod's laser vision moves closer and closer to the
family, he taunts the Man of Steel. Superman
pleads with him to stop, and Zod responds:
"Stop!"
"Never."
With no other choice, Superman snaps
his neck. When Zod dies in his arms,
Superman breaks down and cries.
Killing Zod doesn't exempt Superman from mourning:
he mourns the enemy who ravaged both planets
Kal-El has called home. The scene is pivotal
in Superman's development - having first-hand
experience with how it feels to take a life,
it's cemented in his mind that
he will never do so again.
There are two major deaths in Dawn of Justice,
but no actual last words to speak about. Though
he's a huge villain, Doomsday doesn't exactly
have a final speech, because, well, he doesn't
really speak. But actions speak louder than
words, and threatening to destroy Superman and
the world as we know it is a pretty substantial
action. So we'll count that as his final words.
Superman ends this film in a coffin, though
considering that he comes back later,
his last words here aren't actually his last
words. But part of the significance of his
final words in Dawn of Justice comes from
who they're urgently spoken to. This tension
is evident in what he thinks will be
his last words, which are to Lois Lane:
"This is my world.
You are my world."
Immensely powerful stuff, considering
that he knows exactly what it's like to
lose your whole world. Luckily
for this world, he comes back.
There are quite a few deaths in Suicide Squad,
which is no surprise, based on the movie's title.
Monster T goes early when the crime boss visits
the Joker's club and makes the mistake of ogling
Harley Quinn. When the Joker calls his girlfriend
over and begins taunting Monster T, the gangster
quickly realizes that he's crossed a line.
Wanting to avoid the Joker's jealousy, he says:
"I don't want no beef."
But it's too late, and the Joker
abruptly shoots him in the head.
Slipknot's last words are
a similarly simple tragedy.
Captain Boomerang claims that Amanda Waller
is only playing mind games with them,
and that their heads won't actually explode if
they try to escape. Slipknot asks Boomerang,
"How do you know this?"
Mind games or not, Slipknot gets the answer to his
question. He doesn't survive his escape attempt.
Finally, top Joker henchman Johnny Frost
says some quintessential superhero flick
last words before their helicopter explodes:
"Boss, we got a problem!"
He is, unfortunately, correct.
Enchantress' last words in Suicide Squad
reflect her strong connection to her sibling
and their shared power and past.
Initially she asks for death,
and she's about to have her wish granted.
However, Rick Flag demands that she first
bring June Moone, whose body the witch has
used as a vessel, back to the human world.
Rick doesn't give up the hope of saving June.
When he threatens to crush Enchantress' heart
in his hands if she doesn't bring June
back, Enchantress taunts him and says:
"She's not coming back. Go
ahead. You don't have the balls."
Remembering June's wish that he take
down the sorceress at all costs,
Flag proves Enchantress wrong and crumples the
heart. He's delighted when the act also brings
June back. Enchantress' last words are,
however, a defiant final sentiment - a
fitting end for a goddess who never
stopped wanting to return to her throne.
El Diablo is primed to offer the ultimate
sacrifice, because he's already done the emotional
work of coming to terms with his accidental murder
of his family. When Enchantress telepathically
offers to fulfill the Suicide Squad's deepest
desires, he alone is able to power through his
longing for his wife and children. He's fully
grieved already, and so he can let them go.
A powerhouse emotionally, physically
and supernaturally, El Diablo commits
to a final battle to destroy Incubus.
As the contest progresses and he lures
Incubus into the trap set by the Squad, he
calls out to his team to finish the job.
At this moment, he realizes that he has
to go down in order to vanquish Incubus
once and for all. Just before the two get blown
up, El Diablo utters some pretty great last words:
"Ya chingaste, wey."
For his own part, Incubus doesn't
say much during the final battle;
his last lines in the movie come much earlier,
as he seeks to restore power to his sister.
"Bring me my sister's heart."
DC pulls at our heartstrings in Aquaman when we
see that Black Manta's origin story involves a
heartbreaking goodbye between father and son.
Aquaman confronts Jesse Kane, the father of the
eventual Black Manta David Kane, as he attempts
to hijack a submarine at sea. Unlike some other
heroes, Aquaman has fewer qualms about destroying
villains. After he defeats Jesse and prepares to
leave, Aquaman scolds him for setting such a
bad example. Kane's retaliatory shot breaches
the hull of the submarine and causes a torpedo to
pin him to the wall, effectively sealing his fate.
Regardless of the example Jesse set for
David, it's Aquaman's decision to leave
him to die that really turns the tide
toward vengeance in Black Manta's heart.
Jesse pulls the pin on a grenade so that his son
will leave his side and avoid drowning, saying,
"Hey, you need to live so you can kill
that son of a b---h!
Now go. Go! ... Go."
Thus, a quest for revenge is spawned.
Sid Sivana's story in 2019's Shazam! ends
not in a showdown with a hero, but with his
own brother Thaddeus. Sid's abuses towards his
brother are motivated by grief and resentment:
Thaddeus had, as a young boy, been selected
by the wizard Shazam to become his champion,
but was then rejected due to
impurity of heart. Confused
and hurt, Thaddeus has an angry outburst
while in the car with his father and brother,
causing them to crash and his father to become
crippled. Sid, who goes on to rise in the ranks
of their father's company, blames Thaddeus for the
tragedy and tortures him from that day forward.
The last words of Thaddeus' tormentor are
representative of his abusive temperament.
When Thaddeus, boasting newfound powers,
shows up to a board of directors' meeting
to confront his father, Sid snarls:
"Don't make me throw you out of here,
Thad. You don't need to make a scene."
After this, Thad throws
Sid out the window instead.
In Birds of Prey, Huntress racks up a significant
body count. Among her kills is Victor Zsasz,
a serial killer and employee of Roman
Sionis. Zsasz is paranoid and neurotic,
working with Dinah Lance, aka Black Canary, at
Roman's instruction, but never fully trusting
her. Shortly before he dies, he lets loose on her
after discovering that local thief Cassandra Cain
has swallowed the coveted Bertinelli Diamond,
saying that he knew Dinah couldn't be trusted
and that Roman can only trust him. Dinah tells
him he's just being paranoid. He retorts:
"Oh, yeah? Prove it to me. Rip
open her little tummy. NOW!"
That's the last thing he says
before Huntress shoots him,
and Dinah and Harley finish the
job. Girls gotta stick together.
Black Mask serves as something of a second Joker
to Harley Quinn: his patterns of intimidation and
abuse to her and the women around her nearly
break her. After engaging in a tense exchange
with him as he lurks in the shadows, during
which Harley realizes that "Mr. J" figures
are not her protectors, but her tormentors, she
tries and fails to shoot Black Mask, hitting
a decoy instead. He taunts her, insinuating
that she doesn't stand a chance to defeat him.
But Harley isn't the same Harley any longer.
She's undergone major changes in the way she
thinks about herself and what she deserves.
Harley even tells Cassandra that she
made her want to be a less terrible
person - pretty much the opposite of the impact
the Joker or Black Mask have ever had on her. Roman's reply?
"Ew."
Not very iconic for final words, but a fitting
summation of the condescension Harley faces.
His final dismissal means nothing to the two
young women, however — especially since Cassandra
has planted a bomb on him. Harley kicks the
villain off the bridge as the grenade detonates.
Watchmen begins with Rorschach discovering a
terrible truth, and he eventually dies doing the
same thing. He tries to warn his fellow vigilantes
in the interim, but they don't really take him
seriously. Still, his quest to alert them displays
his doggedness. This is in contrast to those
around him: when an old compatriot ponders what
happened to the good old days of working together,
Rorschach dismisses him by calling him a
quitter, something Rorschach could never do.
His sense of duty and obsessive personality keep
him on the streets, but they also alienate him
from everyone he's ever called an ally, or even a
friend. His final surrender comes as a sacrifice
in service of truth, and his devotion to it.
After he watches Ozymandias traumatize the world,
he realizes the enormity
of what's placed upon him:
he has information that could bring the world
crumbling down, and just as in the beginning,
he can't commit to keeping it quiet. And so
he implores Doctor Manhattan to kill him.
"Well, what are you waiting for? Do it."
He shouts one more time, and
Doctor Manhattan obliges,
leaving nothing but a bloody patch in the snow.
Though the live-action Batman films sustain
plenty of casualties on the villains' side,
most of them are minor characters. After all,
Batman's no-kill rule is central to his identity,
and has deep roots in his violent origins.
The Joker, as a result, rarely dies in any
Batman-related media. Batman has reflected before
on how he can't ever kill the Joker because he
wants to so badly: he knows that if he gave into
that impulse, he might not be able to pull back.
The death of Jack Nicholson's
Joker in 1989's Batman is,
appropriately enough, preceded by these words:
"Sometimes I just kill myself."
It's a demise of his own design: all Batman does
is tether him to a gargoyle, and the Joker's
attempted escape leads to his fatal fall.
Batman keeps to his code ... sort of. As we
see in the next moment, when he saves himself
and Vicki Vale from plummeting to the ground,
Batman has another grappling hook on him.
Does that count in violating his rule?
Time and again, Batman finds himself
dangling from a deadly height,
only for his enemies to meet
their end at the bottom instead.
Two-Face suffers this grisly fate in Batman
Forever. It's a bit hard to tell if this
was an accident: when Two-Face flips his coin at
Batman's suggestion, the hero flusters the villain
by tossing a bunch of decoy coins into the air.
Not inherently a lethal strike, but considering
that Two-Face was balancing on a metal beam at
the time, what else did Bats expect to happen?
As Two-Face prepares to shoot Batman and his crew,
Batman reminds him that he
should let the coin decide,
since he's always of two minds about everything.
Two-Face has an impressive response for him:
"Emotion is always the enemy of true justice.
Thank you. You've always been a good friend."
Some poignant last words to the man
who sort-of-kind-of kills him. But
it's a pretty perfect line, considering that
it's knowing Harvey Dent so well as a friend
and foe that allows the Dark
Knight to best him one last time.
Bane appears to have every advantage
against Batman in The Dark Knight Rises.
His goal is to destroy Gotham
and force Batman to watch,
only allowing him the mercy of death once he's
seen everything he loves go up in flames. But
vengeful mass homicide is complicated. Eventually,
it becomes inconvenient to keep Batman alive,
even though the final stages haven't yet
been executed. This change of plan is
a small sacrifice for Bane, who doesn't seem
overwhelmingly bothered when he tells Batman,
"We both know I have to kill you now.
You'll just have to imagine the fire."
But that never happens,
because he's shot in the chest by Selina
Kyle operating the Batpod's cannon.
The image of Gotham burning is a
bitter threat to this film's Batman,
who has watched his name burn for
eight years to keep Gotham standing.
But Bats will weather the fires of the city's
hatred forever, if it means that Gotham is
safe from the flames. This strength is one that
Bane can never match, and never completely kill.
Ra's al Ghul's death in Batman Begins reflects
Batman's ongoing, internal struggle between
good and evil. The villain was once Batman's
savior and mentor — without him, there would
be no Batman at all. And yet, he's corrupt, and
Batman has to make his peace with that, if he can.
The two adversaries brawl on a runaway train
transporting a microwave emitter that will be
used against Gotham. Ra's holds the upper hand
on his foe, but eventually Batman takes control.
Ra's still taunts our hero when it looks
like Batman is going to kill him and asks,
"Have you finally learned
to do what is necessary?"
Batman replies that he wouldn't take Ra's' life,
but he also doesn't have to
save him. In his last moments,
Ra's realizes that Batman is indeed equipped
to win against injustice — injustice like him.
Batman is simply doing what Ra's taught
him: he's devoting himself to an ideal.
Batman's commitment to compassion is alien
to Ra's.  The League of Shadows is a bit more...
Uh... Let's just say not compassionate when it comes to... well... everything.
This devotion
makes Bruce more than an ordinary man in a cape,
as Ra's claims at the start of their
throwdown - it makes him legendary.
Though the main villains in Batman v. Superman:
Dawn of Justice weren't human, there were
certainly a couple of earthly adversaries who
made things difficult for the good guys. For part
of the film, two of the most vicious of these,
African terrorist General Amajagh and Russian
mercenary Anatoli Knyazev, were working together,
and their last words have a similar ring to them.
Though he didn't have as big of a role in this
film, Knyazev is the alter ego of a DC Comics
supervillain known as KGBeast. Fans are hoping
that somehow or other, the character will get
another chance in the DC Cinematic Universe
that explores the breadth of his presence in
the comics: Multiple people have pointed out that
the original character is cybernetically enhanced,
and that perhaps these modifications could
have been a result of the explosion that,
at least as far as Batman v.
Superman viewers know, killed him.
Perhaps if his last words hadn't been
so threatening, he might have lived.
"I'll kill her! Believe me, I'll do it!"
In his final moments, the warlord Amajagh attempts
to put Superman in a bind by
holding Lois Lane hostage:
"Take one step. You will
see the inside of her head."
Of course, Superman doesn't need to take any
steps at all when he can fly at supersonic speeds:
He rams Amajagh through the wall before
he has the chance to fire the shot.
While it certainly seems like General Amajagh
meets his end at the Man of Steel's hands,
director Zack Snyder left things ambiguous in a
text posted on Reddit, which stated Amajagh was,
quote, "not dead but not a problem either."
Either way, we won't be hearing from him again.
In a superhero universe, dead or alive
status can get a little confusing. But
when a character exits the scene for good,
you can usually pick up on the intent,
and the old Wizard Shazam dissolving into dust
after transferring his powers to Billy Batson
is as good an indication as any. Shazam
lives on, but the old wizard is gone.
Plus, his last words come in the form of an
extremely quotable speech, give background
on the magic and age-old conflicts at play, and
lay the groundwork for Billy to become the hero
he is meant to be. After explaining that his
brothers and sisters have all been wiped out,
Shazam finally convinces the young boy to
speak his name and become the new Champion.
"Carry my name, and with
it you carry all my power."
After that, Billy gets to skip
puberty and become a deep-voiced,
deified superhero. Just before the wizard crumbles
into dust, he offers one more nugget of wisdom:
"With your heart, unlock your greatest power.
The thrones of our brothers and sisters await!"
One of the first victims of Ozymandias'
scheme to unite the world by manufacturing
a nuclear threat is a vigilante known as
the Comedian. With vigilantism outlawed,
a few former vigilantes like the Comedian
became government agents instead,
and when he learned of Ozymandias'
plans, Ozymandias has him killed.
By this time, though, the Comedian is beyond
disillusioned with the state of the world and
the relative powerlessness of any one person
to combat the injustice inherent in it.
By the time he meets his end, The Comedian
had already had his last laugh long ago,
seeing life, and the power structures that
control everything we do, as a huge joke.
Though he fights his assailant to the end,
there's a dull note of defeat in his
voice when he offers his final words:
"It's a joke. It's all a
joke. Mother, forgive me."
In the end, though he had fought for justice all
his life as a vigilante, what he really wanted for
himself was forgiveness for the injustices
he himself chose to commit along the way.
Since Rorschach discovers him dead, Moloch's last
words on film come significantly before his actual
demise must have occurred. In a previous meeting
between the two men. Rorschach confronts Moloch,
a retired supervillain, at his apartment,
demanding to know why Moloch attended the
funeral of the Comedian's civilian alter ego —
and how Moloch knew they were the same person.
Moloch's account details an
encounter with a drunken and
unmasked Comedian who invaded
Moloch's bedroom late at night.
Moloch feared that he was there to kill
him, but the Comedian just wanted to talk.
Seeing that Rorschach is satisfied enough with
his story, Moloch asks if things are settled
between them. Rorschach rummages through one
of his drawers and finds an illegal. Moloch
begs him not to confiscate it, saying that
he's trying any treatment for his cancer.
"You know the kind you eventually get
better from?
That ain't the kind I got."
The 2012 final installment of Christopher
Nolan's Batman trilogy, The Dark Knight Rises,
finds Talia al Ghul carrying on her father's
legacy as one of Batman's chief adversaries,
though she doesn't reveal herself
as such to begin with. Instead,
she elects to have Bane do the dirty work
for her, making it his "personal mission" to
destroy Gotham as her father wanted while Talia
masquerades as Bruce's confidante and lover.
But if you want something done right, eventually
you really do have to do it yourself. That's
why when Batman manages to overpower Bane, Talia
steps in, stabbing the caped crusader. From there,
it's pretty easy to figure out that
she's not who she said she was, but
she helpfully reveals her identity as Ra's al
Ghul's daughter just in case anyone was confused.
Talia has been working to finish what her father
started ever since his death. All she cared about
was vengeance for her father's death and
the realization of his destructive goals,
and her last words pay tribute to her life as she
remotely floods the reactor chamber
that has stabilized an atomic bomb:
"My father's work is done."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.